[Music]
Brothers and sisters, let me introduce
you to Norway. This is a European
country where the vast majority of
people have become irreligious. There
are 200,000 Muslims of a population of
about 5 million. And most of these
200,000 Muslims have no idea how to
explain Islam to their non-Muslim
friends and neighbors. But that needs to
change. Allah sent his messenger to call
people to eternal success. And that is
why Muslims in Norway are now
establishing a masid and da center to
enhance the Norwegian daer. But they
cannot do this alone. We need to support
them. If you donate to this cause, you
will inshallah reap the reward of
thousands of Muslims coming back to
Islam and many of those will become duat
and invite to Islam. You will share in
the reward for all those shahadas and
good deeds to come inshallah. So click
the link and donate now and share the
video for extra reward. Asalam
alalayikum my dear brothers and sisters
in Islam and welcome to another episode
of our Ramadan series where we uncover
the hypocrisy of Islamophobes, debunk
their baseless claims and present the
truth of Islam with clarity and
evidence. In today's episode, we'll be
addressing the claims of Wesley Huff, a
Christian apologist who seems to have
carefully studied the Quran, not to
understand it, but to misrepresent it in
an attempt to undermine its truth. One
of his key arguments revolves around the
Quranic chapter number 10 verse 94. May
Allah subhanaa tala tells the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam if you or
prophet are in doubt about these stories
that we have revealed to you then ask
those who read the scripture before you
the truth has certainly come to you from
your lord. So do not be one of those who
doubt. Huff also uses chapter 5 verse 46
and 47 of the Quran which state then in
the footsteps of the prophets we sent
Jesus the son of Mary confirming the
Torah revealed before him and we gave
him the gospel containing guidance and
light and confirming what was revealed
in the Torah a guide and a lesson to the
god-fearing. So let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
in it and those who do not judge by what
Allah has revealed are truly the
rebellious. He claims that these verses
are proof that the Quran considered the
Bible at the time of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as uncorrupted and that
Christians today still possesses copies
of the Bible from the Arabian Peninsula
in the 6th and 7th century AD. Codex and
Brininius. These copies contain the same
core Christian doctrines found in other
versions of the Bible dating back to the
7th century which proves that the Bible
was never altered. According to him,
this presents an irrefutable
contradiction. If the Quran affirms the
truth of the Bible at the time, yet the
Bible contradicts the Quran, then the
Quran must be false. Let's hear him
explain this so-called logic himself.
But this brings me back to chapter 5 46
and 47 of the Quran. In order to take
this passage seriously, a passage that
addresses me personally as a person of
the gospel, a Christian, I run into a
problem. If I judge the Quran by the
Gospel, which I am commanded to do in
order to not be one of the defiantly
disobedient, I find that the Quran
misunderstands, lacks comprehension of,
and outright contradicts the Torah and
the Gospel. So if the Quran is true and
I obey it in this instance by the
standards it tells me to judge by, I
find the Quran false. So we've heard
what he has to say. Basically he's
saying that the Quran teaches you you
need to follow the Bible. And when the
Bible contradicts the Quran, then that
proves the Quran to be false. What do
you have to say about that? Well, I
think there's a fundamental
misunderstanding of Islamic theology
from this person who has been recently,
I think, on J Joe Rogan's show. And
actually, it's a very weak kind of
assessment of Islamic theology because
it's something no Islamic scholar has
ever understood Islam to mean. I'll
start firstly with the first claim that
he mentions in chapter number five verse
number 47. Uh that um Allah mentions
that basically, you know, um you've got
you've got to rule by the Torah, right?
and so on. And then it
[Music]
says, "And whoever does not rule by what
Allah has revealed in the other
disbelievers." I mean, all it takes is
for him to have read the next verse
which says
that okay now this is very important
phrase because actually this terminology
is used to describe Allah. So what does
the verse mean? It says and we have sent
down the book i the Quran. Now, okay, we
have sent down the Quran to you in
truth to affirm that which has come
before it. And we'll explain what that
means in a second or in which that which
will
follow and a guardian over it. Muhe is a
guardian. In this context, there's no
there's nothing this word can mean
except that it's it's a distinguisher
from what is true and what is false. And
that is what the morestors or the
exedutes of old and in the contemporary
period have all understood the word to
mean. Meaning what? That from the
corrupted versions of the Bible from the
corrupted versions of and we don't even
believe in the Bible. The Quran does not
mention the word biblio oro bible which
means book in the Greek language. It's
not something that's mentioned in the
Quran. But say for the sake of argument
the corrupted version of Torat the
corrupt corrupted versions of the injil
which don't even exist because there was
no one gospel of Jesus anywhere. There's
only the gospels according to Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John and so on and so
forth. But going back, even that
corrupted version of Torat, Allah says
in the Quran in the very next verse that
he does for some reason conspicuously
omits. Yeah. Says that the Quran is
going to be that which distinguishes
truth from falsehood in that regard. So
that already breaks the argument that we
have to use the the Old Testament and
the New Testament somehow the corrupted
versions thereof in today's world and
the contents therein as some kind of
ultimate authority especially one as he
goes on to say in a very problematic and
actually comical sense an authority over
the Quran itself. Uh so that's the first
thing. The second thing is well why
doesn't he read the Quran in its
entirety? It looks to me that he's
following the footsteps of those
apologists, Christian apologists, who
have used this Quranic dilemma argument,
which has flopped time and time again. I
see you didn't get bored by the champ.
Huh, I like that. But make sure you
click the link below and donate to the
mega message project I mentioned.
Once once again, I've been in the field
for many years. There's not been one
Muslim I have met that has so much has
been affected by this uh misconception
because they realize this weakness. But
we'll continue and say how would you
explain the question would go how would
you explain the fact that the Quran
mentions for example in chapter number
three verse number 187 for instance and
there are many verses like it but I'm
just choosing this one for now because
this verse is clear about Christians and
Jews the books of the Christians and the
books of the Jews.
that they have thrown it behind their
backs and it's obviously a figure of
speech. But if you look at what mentions
about this verse, it
means they have lost it. They have lost
the books. They have not been able to
preserve the books. That's what it
means. Clearly the Quran is telling this
person and the Christian world that
which Christian scholarship today has
already confirmed that which Bruce Mezc
in his masterpiece in his seinal work
his magnumopus has confirmed in his book
talking about the corruption of the
Bible. I don't think there's anybody now
to be taken seriously that says that the
book the Bible has not got contradictory
versions. the New International the
Revised Standard Version, this that
version, all contradicting one another.
Some things that have been added into
the in the books that were not there.
Witness in heaven, the father, son, and
holy spirit. Was it the record in
heaven? For there are three that bear
the record in heaven. The father, the
son, and the holy spirit. Now almost
everyone considers that to be an
interpolation,
a fabrication, something which was not
in the Bible, then was put into the
Bible, which means that there's been a
corruption process. Okay? You don't find
the equivalent in the Quranic discourse.
Now on the other point that he made
where he mentions in ununas that it
mentions
that that go and ask the people who have
been given the book before you. Yeah. Go
and ask the people. You know it's very
interesting
because he mentions according to and
I've checked the chain of narration is
an authentic chain of narration. Very
interesting how he addressed this
verse because the verse starts if you
are in any doubt from that which has
been revealed to you. Then go and ask
the people of the book that came before
you. That's what the verse says.
Yeah. But I'm sure this man is clever
enough to understand that this is a
conditional. A conditional if you are in
doubt. So what Adam Jubel mentions one
of the the early people and that's
mentioned he didn't doubt and he didn't
ask
do you see if you were in doubt go and
ask but he wasn't in doubt so he did not
ask so it's it's irrelevant there was no
there is no direct command in the Quran
that tells the prophet without condition
to go to the Jews and Christians and
seek ultimate authority uthority for
them in such a manner that would render
the Quran itself as a secondary
authority. In fact, all of the all of
the evidence shows the opposite. And I
think that this argument has now failed.
It's a weak argument. No one accepts it.
No one's convinced of it. It's shallow
apologetics. It's weak. It's
superficial. It's a It is a lowbrow. It
is a superficial. It is a uh unworthy
interrogation of Islam and as such we
don't really have to say much more. This
this interrogation has failed. That's
true. Game over. That's game over. Yeah,
it's game over.
So, let's tune into something even more
important than addressing this this
baseless claim. And that's brothers and
sisters. For a long time now, we have
been raising funds to establish a
one-of-a-kind mega masid and dawa center
in Norway. And alhamdulillah, thanks to
your generous donations, we have
purchased this huge building that we are
in right now. We are inside it right
now. This studio that we are sitting in
right now is part of this masid complex.
And we've done so much refurbishment
inside and we've started so many
activities here. You've been here.
You've seen it. We We have classes for
the children, teaching them Islam,
teaching them how to defend Islam, being
proud of, not just that, but how to
defend themselves. You've got now
martial arts classes. You got football.
It was such a positive vibe when I went
and saw the classrooms. That was
fantastic. And to be honest with you,
this is a vibrant environment. And it's
not just here. Look, we are launching
intellectual missiles all over the
world. Yeah. All over the world. This
stuff is being translated into multiple
languages, into Arabic, into this, into
that. It's going everywhere. Yeah. This
is reaching millions of people. That's
true. Oh my god. I could and these
people know the prophetam mentioned
that the one who is who guides to the
truth is like the one who does the
truth. The one who does who who shows
where the good deeds are is like the one
who does the good
deeds. So what are you waiting for?
Let's be honest. What are you waiting
for? You've got them. Allah has blessed
you. This is a test. Allah has given you
a test. He's put you give you certain
money. He won't see what you're going to
do with it. It's a test. It's a test.
Now, are you going to give to causes
which you know are going to help our
generations, our Muslims, or are you
going to sorry to say, you know, just
pretend you're not hearing what I'm
saying right
now? This what me and F would know to be
honest. But we have a good opinion of
you because if it wasn't for them, we
wouldn't be here. That's true. This
wouldn't be here. That's true. we
wouldn't be recording these videos this
Ramadan series and so many other series
and programs that we planned for we
wouldn't be able to do that because of
you it's because of your generous
support Allah but let's see how generous
they'll be and that be that will be the
test for today for I think they will be
generous it's the month of Ramadan the
month of generosity the month of
generous well these are the loyalists
you know what you're right I agree with
you these guys are going to click that
link below right now I don't see how
they won't do that they're doing it
already Yeah, I'm scrolling. Come on
scrolling. Click the link below, guys.
Click the link and take part in this
tremendous tremendous rewards that will
inshallah be added to your scale of good
deeds.
[Music]